le point météo de la pluie de la pluie
et encore de la pluie le weekend de la
pente-côte avait des fauxes air de
weekend de la toussin et cela ne devrait
pas s'améliorer au cours des prochains
jours il faudra sans doute attendre le
début du mois de juin pour constater une
légère amélioration mélodie Locar elodim
moine se sont rendus au centre de Météo
France attrape pour plus de précisions
effectivement et c'est le moins qu'on
puisse dire la météo n'a pas été bonne
en ce weekend prolongé aujourd'hui la
situation ne s'est pas non plus
améliorée je suis devant le centre
département de météorologie à trappe et
c'est d'ailleurs cette ville qui a
enregistré les plus fortes
précipitations de tout le département
durant la pon de côte il est tombé en 3
jours ce qu'il PL en moyenne en un mois
hier on a même relevé 39,5 mm de pluie
dans les zones de trappe et de la plaine
de Versailles un record jamais atteint
depuis 1904 l'année où météo France a
commencé ses calculs alors est-ce que
nous allons pouvoir ranger nos
parapluies cette semaine réponse avec
Emmanuel vert prévisionniste à Météo
France
dans les prochains jours ça devrait être
un petit peu plus sec que ce qu'on a
connu au cours du weekend de la
pente-côte mais il existe encore un
risque de précipitation plutôt sous
forme d'averse dans les jours qui
viennent avec des températures qui
restent en dessous des normales de
saison avec un petit radoucissement
demain mercredi puis de nouveau un
rafraîchissement pour jeudi et vendredi
suivi d'une petite osse en fin de
semaine donc à partir de samedi ou
dimanche et en début de semaine
prochaine